hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from round five of the
feed a grand prix currently being played
in belgrade but also a really weird game
uh because it gets uh well
it gets to a point of actually winning
the game or you know before the move 10
has even been reached pretty much so
it's um
kind of cool in that perspective but
also
it doesn't end there but it lasts for
some 60 moves now uh much like in game
four uh all of the games in round five
ended in a draw except for this one that
may or may not have ended in a draw i
will have to check it out and see
what actually happened so it's witted
versus rapport uh let's see uh what's
going on here so e4 we have e6 rapper
goes for the french defense we have d
for d5 and now e5 it goes for the
advanced variation of the french and now
c5 so very principle striking in the
center as white over extended with e5 uh
and now c3 i just uh perfecting the
setup here and now queen to b6 putting
more pressure to the center here putting
pressure on b2 so white has some trouble
developing the bishop here uh this is a
very very popular knight to c6 still by
far the most popular but queen this
queen to v6 also uh incredibly popular
knight to f3 and bishop the d7 now this
is the weight variation of the french
and the idea is to trade uh one pawn in
the center and play bishop to b5 and
trade off
white's light square bishop as a white
slice square bishop you know it can be
an incredibly strong piece in the
against the french defense and the black
slide square bishop uh will not be doing
all that much so best just trade it off
right away that's the idea uh bishop to
e2 and now c captures on d4 we have c
captures and bishop to b5 so the bishop
trade is being offered here we have
bishop captures with czech queen
captures and the knights the c3 now
attacking the queen here queen to a6
rapport not allowing invaded to the
castle and if it plays a4 so there are a
couple of uh uh
games that reach this exact same
position and couple of other moves that
have been played here uh but a for not
this one so it's now as of multender we
have a completely new game uh here we
have bishop to b4 uh not allowing
knights to b5 because with a4 video
would like to play knight to b5 so the
white king will be able to castle and
you will have an excellent outpost for
the knight as black does not have a c
pawn so he will not be able to kick it
away at least not while the queen is on
a6 and the a6 cannot be played so here
bishop to d2 unpinning and now bishop
captures on c3 so not allowing that
knight to be five bishop captures and
now knight to e7 going after that
beautiful f5 square as the light square
bishops have been uh taken off the board
and now b4 video now says all right i'm
playing b5 and then i'm definitely
castling and rapper says nope that's not
happening he's playing queen to c4 uh
still keeping an eye on this diagonal so
not allowing castles and putting
pressure on the bishop what not a
problem we have rook to c1 and now
knight beat the c6 and here's uh when
the fun really starts uh so okay i said
that the game reaches a critical uh
point already in the opening uh on move
10 it's actually move 14 but still it's
i mean completely crazy for a classical
game so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find uh uh well uh a
completely mad idea for white while i
give you a couple of seconds to give
white a chance at a winning position
so uh have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing this
incredible truth as this is incredibly
hard to find and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is knight
to d2 that's the move uh vidit did not
play it because uh well it's uh so ugly
and so complicated and seemingly
impossible to calculate that uh it seems
that you'll just spend all of your time
calculating this and you know still
still not be done with all of the lines
but to give it to you uh as as briefly
as possible okay now black's queen is
attacked we have to move the queen
somewhere not a lot of squares for the
queen you can't go to a6 then b5 and
that's game so here queen to d3 would be
played and now comes the move you had to
see and that is pawn to b5 and what do
you do here well obviously you capture
the pawn other other lines aren't all
that impressive but um
capturing the pawn is is the best idea
for black and after knight captures on
d4 now comes the move you really had to
see and that's the really hard one and
that is h4 and now when you see rook
coming to h3 you see that the knight
here really doesn't have all that much
to do because uh once rook h3 comes
we're gonna have to move the queen and
you're gonna lose the knight and if you
try to save the knight let's say you try
something like knight to f5 well then
it's even worse now comes rook h3 and
now you've taken away the two squares
the black queen could actually use the
uh get away from uh from the rook and
now you you just lose the queen so
there's nothing to be done here so what
you would have to do after this h4 move
is maybe try play knight captures on b5
give up the knight for these two pawns
because you already grabbed one pawn and
then start marching your pawns forward
but here white would just play bishop to
b2 and say rook h3 is still coming and
your knight still has no squares rook
covers c7 pawn covers d6 uh where is
your knight going uh n
nothing to play here for black so once
you castle rook h3 is coming and then
after something like queen g6 we're
gonna play rook g3 first harass the
queen a bit more and after queen to h6
we're gonna play even rook to g for
garder pawn here uh and the knight still
has no squares and let's say knight g
knight g6 goes after the h4 pawn now we
capture on b5 and finally after knight
captures on h4 you get king to f1 now we
have to put the king on g1 all the way
so we don't have to worry about queen to
h1 but all in all here white is just up
a piece yes okay you don't have an h
pawn but your king will be very safe
here and white is completely winning
here so uh after knight b to c6 rapport
allowed this but who would see who would
see this if you found knight to d2
that's incredibly impressive if you
found the three ideas knight the knight
to d2 b5 and h4 allowing the rook to
come to h3 uh then you truly sir are an
incredible player
uh so here uh instead of knight to d2
bishop to dt was played opening up an
attack against rapport's queen but now
queen to d3 and now b5 doesn't really do
anything because you cannot connect it
with uh with h4 rook coming to h3
there's a knight on f3 so rook h3 will
really be doing nothing so here queen e2
offering a queen trade and rapper
declines this very politely with queen
to a3 and now again what do you play
here well here vid is just castle but
now now was also a good time to play b5
but still it's not uh easy to to realize
why because after knight to a5
which is uh well silly move because it's
hanging but it's really not because the
bishop has to guard the rook on uh c1 so
if capturesqueen's gonna capture here so
we would see rook to c7 putting pressure
on the b7 and the e7 square and now
knight to c4 closing up the c file so
now we're going to chase the rook here
and after let's say castles we're going
to play king d8 and after rook captures
on b7 king the c8
and now you will have to give up the
exchange but okay let's say bishop c1
queens goes somewhere and now rook
captures on e7 queen captures we would
get this position where uh white uh
sacrificed the exchange but white also
has a very very uh promising position
with the king being wide in the open so
this would be favorable for white but
okay uh here uh we have uh after queen
a3 oh sorry we have castles and now
comes knight to f5 this knight will now
enjoy being here very much uh you don't
have a light square bishop so the only
way to kick it away is to play g4 and
well white
not interesting in doing that just yet
and now uh you don't have b5 anymore
because now the knight can just capture
as this knight is also attacking the d4
square so bishop c3 video defense now
comes rook to c8 we have g4 you have to
get rid of this knight otherwise the
black's position is just too powerful
knight f to e7 and now bishop back to d2
opening up the c file
and here we have uh h5 uh interestingly
if you go after the b4 pawn as the pawn
is hanging there's trouble for black
here because there's rook to a1 and now
once let's say we trade queens captures
captures we're going to play rook after
b1 and you will lose the b7 pawn uh so
that's not really good for lag because
if you try to defend it let's say you
play b6 then rule b3 and you lose the
knight again no squares for the knight
the pawns are just so so nicely placed
so instead after bishop d2 rapport
strikes with h5 he says all right now g4
has been made a target g captures on h5
and now queen captures on a4
we have rook to a1 attacking the queen
queen back to c2 and now b5 so finally
this b5 move is played knights to d8 the
knights uh uh seemingly terribly placed
are actually doing a good job at keeping
everything safe rook after c1 attacking
the queen and queen to f5 now uh video
trades a pair of rooks we have rook
captures knight captures and now rook to
c1 putting pressure on the knight but
knight just goes back knight to e7 and
here as the c7 square is now available a
video goes for the rook lift you could
choose between a rook c7 and bishop to
b4 those are the two moves you want to
play but it starts with rook the c7
we have rook captures on h5 now bishop
to b4 pressuring the knight on e7 now
knight to g6 and here finally b6 but now
uh okay
you are
making making some progress here you
want to play queen to b5 check but the
problem is black is already up a pawn
and now you give black an opportunity to
be up two pawns and rapport does not um
uh well uh allow this opportunity to to
pass he just plays queen to b1 check and
now look at this okay if the king goes
to g2 then we just play knight f4 check
and we win the game on the spot so uh
you have to block check with the queen
so queen to e1 was played and now uh we
have a a a trade here queen captures
knight captures and a captures on b6 and
now we have this position uh where it's
six black pawns against four white pawns
and that's that's quite a lot so here we
have knight to c2 now comes rook to h3
activating the rook preparing to shift
the rook over to the queen side we have
bishop to d6 an excellent square for the
bishop
unfortunately it's not going to be doing
all that much here knight to c6 now
offering the b7 pawn for some counter
play against the d4 pawn so rook captain
and here
going for the capture right away might
not be the the best course of action
maybe best is just to play rook c8 to
check and now
after let's say knights to d and knight
to d8 bring the rook back to c7 and
force black to find a different plan but
okay
we played rook captures on b7 right away
and now we have rook to c3 attacking the
defender of the d4 pawn knights the e3
and now even knights the h4 yeah so
first we're going to improve the
position of our knight before uh before
going after the pawn and now king to f1
here if you go
for rook captures here the knight
captures here nothing really good there
for white so instead rook uh
rook to b3 was played and now comes
knight to c2 we have rooked the b2
attacking the knight now comes knight to
a3 we have knight f1 knight f5 going
after the d4 pawn now comes bishop to c5
defending and now finally knight f
captures on d4 and now okay now you
could capture on b6 but this is a lost
end game rogue captures bishop captures
after knight f3 you attack this pawn in
this pawn so white will have to give up
one of them let's say h4 knight captures
here you're up two pawns of course this
is completely winning so instead after
knight f captures on d4 we have h4 the
pawn will be a little bit safer there
but still knight f5 goes after the pawn
bishop to d6 now
as this pawn also needs to be defended
and now rook b3 puts pressure on the
knight we have knight to c2 now comes d4
now our rapport starts pushing his pass
pawn king the e1 now knight captures on
h4 so everything is winning here for
black it's only a matter of technique so
f4 we have knight to f3 check king to f2
now comes knight captures on e5 even
this is possible because the knight will
be
uh well the knight cannot cannot escape
the rook so f captures an e5 and now
comes rook to b2 attacking the knight
the knight cannot move of course king to
f3 rook captures on c2 and now rook
captures on b6 we have rook to c3 check
king to f4 and now f6 so there are no
moves here for white uh we have e
captures on f6 g captures rook to b7 uh
but uh even though with with such a
beautifully active rook and the bishop
nicely placed on d6 there just aren't
any threats here for white so rook to c4
are going for some discoveries here now
comes bishop to a3 and rook to a4 going
after the bishop bishop to c1 and
finally rook to a7 chasing the rook away
from the seventh rank uh you can win
this a lot of ways but this is the the
safest one rook to b6 and king to d7 we
have king to e4 now comes f5 with check
king to d3 and of course e5 the pawns
are now marching forward very nicely
king to c4 now comes king to d6 bishop
to d2 but now rook to a2 attacking the
bishop and finally bishop to be for
check king to c7 attacks the rook and
bishop the c5 defending rook the c to
check king to d5 you have to guard the
bishop and now knight to e7 check and he
was in this position on move 61 that uh
vidit resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here once the
knight is captured nothing is regarding
your rook so it's pretty much simple as
that captures captures and once once you
capture here we can even play queen king
rookie do check and pick up the the
bishop here and just push our pawn to
victory and other moves don't really
help with it all that much if king to e6
we can just capture on c5 now the rook
is hanging if king captures an e7 you're
just down a whole rook and lastly uh for
example after this knight to e7 check
you could capture an e5 but still just
root characters and c5 check pretty much
the same thing captures here we're going
to capture here uh this is the worst of
the three of course so after 97 check
that it resigned and a beautiful victory
for rapport in round five of the
belgrade feed a grand prix
uh so we'll see what happens today is
the final round before the before the
knockout so i think anish still has the
lead pretty sure about that maybe
rapport caught up to him but uh if not
it's either anish or rapport and anish
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and again special
congratulations to anyone who found
knight f2d to hear uh you know and the
following ideas this is just an
incredible position that uh
i think uh both of them will remember
for for a very long time
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys uh enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank gregory boshko you for buying from
closebox.com uh congrats for the new job
elizabeth
greetings from zdravka boost and zoolong
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
prix until it finishes uh thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day